hi mi so if I jump the bridge goes out
haha oh yeah ah something that you guys
are now thinking that I am a giant idiot
ah not stupid haha yes Wow
afraid that he was gonna blow up I like
how that I have a string quartet behind
me every time something pops out just
for guys Bobby just that was happening a
little blue those brass I really do like
to about the atmosphere
this game doesn't rely on a string
quartet oh my back just has a guy
playing a sousaphone in my ear
stop that sousaphone man
it's perfect
it's a perfect strategy what not
all right Mario games laughs and Wade
being loose I seem to be spreading
things around block yes reddit losing
all over boy like butter it's getting
real dirty in your boy
oh so dirty that's the way I like it
such a dirty boy mark
I tried why are you going I'm almost
done me too what are you doing give me a
kiss we're doing something wrong I'm
actually a big fan of Spongebob how
about no how about you make your own
damn dinner you son of a [ __ ]
you've been mooching on me for years
eating my stuff in the fridge that's
clearly been liable for a bit ha ha I'm
a goofy goober yeah you're a goofy
goober yeah we're all goofy goobers yeah
give me give me give me give me give her
yeah I know okay nevermind Oh what is
that Wow what what what time period is
this I just saw a jet go by Merc I don't
like none of you what the hell yeah I
don't know I don't care let's just find
it you a jelly bean you look like a
jelly bean
am I missing something here because
something does not seem right I'm trying
to control my language this is a very
kid-friendly game
oh god dammit your mother humper
son of a [ __ ] as a child I wished that
I could get on the floor and gobble up
little gray balls not weird in any way I
don't know what your childhood was like
yeah baby
but markiplier gots to go back nothing
guys last level what is all of that what
is all that yes you took your time
didn't you
so I just need to drop down here so that
I can go over here
oh is it I was but I always think like
it's summoning slender by this just big
noise like oh sander coming for dinner
some stupid idiot wandered into your
woods again yeah I'm getting good it is
Oh Oh as you can probably could probably
tell I turned on I turned on the I
turned on the speech jammer at a speech
jammer is it it's a device that loops
your own voice but your own voice into
your ears on a Dilla day so that you
can't understand you can't understand
when you're done talking now we're back
to the level that we're beginning into
that we're getting it to the other that
we're gonna get it because I'm so
focused on what's happening what's
happening in my ear balls I don't have
ear balls no one has it here no no but
no one hasn't has ear balls what they
have I'm looking at these balls in the
game I've got I can't thanks for
watching all of the videos in this
compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more of a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye